ومع ايام رمضان قد يتناسى البعض شرب الماء
لكن ذلك قد لا يسبب العطش فقط الطبيب
البريطانيه جولييت هوبسن اكدت ان قله شرب
الماء قد تؤدي الى الشعور بالام في الظهر
كما اشارت لنا الكثيرين يعانون من اوجاع
مختلفه نتيجه قله المياه التي يشربونها ما
يؤدي لالام مختلفه لاسيما في الفقرات
والعظام الظهريه الطبيبه اوضحت ان العظم
والمفاصل تحتاج الى التليين والترطيب الذي
يؤدي اليه شرب الماء بكميات مناسبه هو
الامر الذي يخفى عنه كثيرا
[موسيقى]
اما الان فنذهب الى علاء
العديد من لصوص الماء يتكاثرون حولنا في
ليالي رمضان ليشعرون بالعطش في نهاره
الطويل هؤلاء اللصوص يزيدون الشعور بالعطش
ومنهم الماكولات التي تحتوي على التوابل
والبهارات حيث تزيد الشعور بالرغبه بشرب
الماء بكثره كذلك فان الاكثار من الكافيين
والصودا يزيد من طلب الماء في الجسم خلال
فتره الصيام ايضا السكريات جزء من المشكله
فالاكثار منها يزيد الرغبه بشرب الماء
وكذلك المشي في الشمس والتعرض لها بكثره
يزيد من احضار الماء من الجسم وبالتالي
العطش المتزايد واخيرا تناول اللحوم
المجففه والمملحه والمخللات والاسماك كلها
مسببات اضافيه للعطش